[Música]
salud en directo américa ya está con
nosotros nuevamente en el estudio más
romeros a la mar bienvenida una semana
más de directo américa hoy se conmemora
el día mundial de la malaria una
enfermedad tratable y prevenible pero
que sigue causando estragos
lamentablemente más buenos días raúl
pues si estamos hablando de
aproximadamente 600 mil muertes anuales
241 millones de contagios éstos son
cifras orientativas del 2020 y todo esto
teniendo en cuenta que más del 90 por
ciento tanto de las muertes como de los
casos registrados suceden en el
continente africano lo que la convierte
en una enfermedad que a pesar de ser
global es increíblemente desigual en su
repartimiento no de la carga para hablar
de esta enfermedad de los tratamientos y
de la lucha contra la malaria estamos
con carlos pérez médico infectólogo de
la universidad nacional de colombia
doctor buenos días y muchas gracias por
acompañarnos en este lunes en directo
américa la enfermedad de la malaria
afecta de manera desproporcionada a los
niños estamos hablando que el 80 por
ciento de las muertes ocurre en menores
de 5 años a qué se debe
si marc hoy conmemoramos la lucha contra
la malaria que afecta principalmente a
niños y a niños africanos donde se
concentra el 80% y más de la mortalidad
los niños son mucho más se utilizan las
complicaciones especialmente la malaria
cerebral y afecta porque generalmente
son niños desnutridos o con grandes
riesgos en su salud donde una enfermedad
como estas puede ser devastadora sin
embargo la malaria afecta a toda la
humanidad y en todas las edades
principalmente la mortalidad en esta
población infantil pero es una
enfermedad universal como lo mencionadas
pero especialmente sensible en la
población infantil y de alto riesgo así
es doctor los saludo gracias por estar
normalmente con nosotros en salud de
directo américa en octubre del año 2021
se anunció la primera vacuna de la
historia contra la marea la malaria le
preguntó el impacto que puede tener este
fármaco
a la vacuna se ha trabajado desde hace
muchos años de décadas distintas las
vacunas que conocemos hoy del coi que
son para virus este es para un parásito
porque hace que sea mucho más compleja
para su desarrollo y además de eso esta
vacuna tiene dificultades para su
administración su evaluación y su real
impacto en el 2019 se hizo la fase 3
recordemos que son cuatro fases y en
este momento hay un proyecto piloto en
tres países de áfrica donde se está
evaluando la capacidad para disminuir lo
que se sabe hoy de la vacuna este reduce
las complicaciones de la malaria sobre
todo la mortalidad pero no la enfermedad
como tal pero eso es un gran avance en
una enfermedad que por décadas pasó está
aplica a otros países y no hemos tenido
ninguna respuesta desde
inmunológico efectivo doctores sin
embargo la organización mundial de la
salud calcula que se podrían salvar
aproximadamente podría llegar a salvarse
80 mil vidas con la administración de
esta vacuna anual es entonces porque
todavía no se está distribuyendo
masivamente qué es lo que hace falta
para que eso
hoy está poniéndose en esa fase en esa
prueba piloto en los países africanos
esperando y hablando recordemos que esta
es una enfermedad que tiene
complicaciones que tienen que verse a
mediano oa corto plazo y se esté
hablando esa efectividad para poderle
expandir globalmente esta es una vacuna
que reduce 40% pero eso ya es muy
significativo en las complicaciones
graves de la malaria es probable que en
los próximos 5 años en la próxima década
ya tenga una expansión de la vacuna para
otras poblaciones y estamos esperando la
terminación de estas paz piloto y esto
es fase 3 que son importantes para
evaluar la seguridad y la eficacia así
es doctor y también la oim ee se quiere
eliminar la malaria pero le pregunto que
hace falta realmente para poder
erradicarla
la malaria está acompañada también de
unos problemas sociales que hablaba más
de esa simetría de la pobreza pero tiene
otros mecanismos es una enfermedad que
es curable sin ser para mí si quedan los
fármacos a tiempo y prevenible si se
usan repelentes y protecciones como los
mosquiteros impregnados de estos
repelentes para evitar el contacto con
el parásito además de mejorar las
condiciones sociales el problema son
esos retos el acceso a los sistemas de
salud el acceso a los tratamientos en
sitios remotos que haya personal médico
calificado de laboratorio para hacer un
diagnóstico temprano por eso es una
enfermedad compleja pero que tiene todo
para poderse prevenir tratamiento
efectivo medidas preventivas y una
actualmente un doctor para terminar
rápidamente cuál es la situación de la
malaria en américa latina
en américa latina nos afecta en los
bordes costeros
y en poblaciones también de alto riesgo
donde hay alta infestación
de estos parásitos a través de las
hembras de los anopheles que son estas
mosquitos que llevan la malaria nosotros
tenemos un gran y un gran problema sobre
todo regional en donde están en las
zonas costeras y también en poblaciones
marginales desplazadas o que están muy
alejados de centros poblacionales para
nosotros era importante tener una una
como estas y estamos pendientes de que
todos los gobiernos locales regionales y
toda la comunidad esté pendiente de una
enfermedad prevenible y tratable hoy muy
probablemente tenga medidas preventivas
pero que afecta a los más necesitados
doctor gracias por estar con nosotros
nuevamente en salud de directo américa
mar también gracias a por acompañarnos
como siempre en su sección de salud
pasamos a saludar a nuestro segundo
invitado del día